peut après prabhjeet singh
Mes aubes sont à nouveau professeur de coupures de porno
envoie-le en anglais, comprends, merci
fais-le
Est arrivé
Un aperçu de la location de trains à distance
les voleurs
montre plus
fais-le
Est arrivé
que le premier sens scientifique a été utilisé
Insignifiant Mirwaiz a réalisé
[musique]
fais-le
Une mère connectée uniquement à la forêt
avoir le droit
[musique]
Que Karan et Tik Tok respectent
Les plus grands ministres les plus longs que nous ayons connus
Accédez aux vidéos de Baïkunth que personne ne peut voir
Regardez les vidéos contactez-nous
[musique]
Certaines personnes nous ont rejoint sur place et puis
S'il y a ne serait-ce qu'un peu de colère parmi les gens, alors nous
Quoi qu'il en soit, il y en a un peu.
fais-le
Qui sont les villageois comme nous qui
Ils n'ont de plateforme nulle part
Et ne sont pas en mesure de montrer leur talent
Il était donc capable de bien voir à travers la pop
J’ai l’impression que nous avons reçu un très mauvais coup.
Cela signifie que cela fait au moins un an et demi que j'ai le système.
J'ai travaillé très dur en conduisant
Pour augmenter le flop et ces gens aussi
Mes bons comptes mais du coup bannis
Cela a été un choc quand cela s’est produit, mais tout le reste est une autre affaire.
Que tout ce que notre pays veut arrive et je
Je n'irai pas à l'encontre de leur décision
Est arrivé
[musique]
fais-le
à Ajay
[musique]
qu'un
Est arrivé
filet